And the Grammy goes to "Sour," Olivia Rodrigo.
Oh, wow!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you again to the recording academy.
Thanks to all the fans who have listened to my music...
...and completely changed my life over the past two years.
I really want to dedicate this award to my parents.
When I was nine years old, I told my mom I was going to be an Olympic gymnast...
...even though I could barely do a cartwheel,...
...and she thought I was joking, but I'm super defensive.
And so, the next week when I told her I was going to win a Grammy,...
...she was very supportive even though I'm sure she thought...
...it was just a little kid pipe dream.
But I want to thank my mom for being supportive of all of my dreams...
...no matter how crazy,...
...and I want to thank my mom and my dad for being equally as proud of me...
...for winning a Grammy as they were when I learned how to do a back walkover.
This is for you guys and because of you guys, thank you.